Welcome to the Do Bao Nam Blog computer
channel. In today's video, Do Bao Nam
Blog will share with you how to start a
new page in Word on all versions. In
this video, Do Bao Nam Blog will share
with you two ways to start a new page
at any position in a Word file. The
first method is using the Ctrl plus
Enter keyboard shortcut. For example,
now I will move this entire section of
text to a new page. The steps you need
to take are as follows. First, place
your cursor at the beginning of the
content that you want to move to a new
page. Here, I will place it at this
first position. Then, for the second
step, press the Ctrl plus Enter key
combination on your keyboard.
Immediately, the part where I placed
the cursor has been moved to a new page
. Similarly, right now, the bottom of
this second page is blank. Now, I don't
want to enter content here anymore, but
instead, I want to enter it on the next
page. Usually, you might press the
Enter key multiple times here. However,
this is not the best way. To go to a
new page, you just need to place your
cursor right after the content. Then,
also press the Ctrl plus Enter keys.
This is page 3. Now I will zoom out. As
you can see, I currently have three
pages. Next, I will move on to the
second method for starting a new page
in Word, which is using the ribbon. For
example, now I will go to page 2 and
move the content of the second
paragraph to a new page. The steps you
need to take are as follows. First,
place your cursor at the beginning of
the content that needs to be moved to a
new page, which is this position. Then,
for the second step, click on Layout in
the menu, select Breaks, and then
select Next Page. As you can see, my
second paragraph has been moved to a
new page, and now I have four pages in
this text file. Thus, in the video
content just now, Do Bao Nam Blog has
quickly shared with you two ways to
start a new page in Word that are both
fast and simple. Thank you for watching
the video. Goodbye and see you in the
next videos. If you find my video
interesting and useful, please click
Like and share the video to support Do
Bao Nam Blog. Also, if you haven't
subscribed to the Do Ba Nam Blog
channel yet, please click the subscribe
button and select the bell icon. Click
"All" to subscribe and receive more
useful videos from Do Ba Nam Blog.
Thank you very much. Additionally, you
can search on Google using the keyword
Do Ba Nam Blog. And visit the website
dobanamblog.com or the Do Ba Nam Blog
YouTube channel to watch more useful
videos on computer tips, Style Pro, and
how to use software like Word, Excel,
PowerPoint, and so on. And you can
visit the website dobanamblog.com to
stay updated with the latest useful
articles. Thank you for watching the
video.